foreign
[Music]
independent presents our virtual Edition
I'm Kate Mason with film independent uh
before we get started with today's very
exciting q a I have to give some praise
to our supporters I want to thank our
incredible lead sponsor the Hollywood
Foreign Press Association and our
screening partner Vision media and with
that let's get into it I'm so excited to
introduce our moderator SiriusXM host
and comedian Dean obidala welcome thanks
very much Kate so right now very happy
to be here and also it's a thrill to
introduce my friend the co-creator
executive producer and star of Mo plays
monajar Mo armor Mo good to see you my
friend congratulations on the series
thank you brother man good to see you
man looking sharp I got this Holy Chic
look you know what I mean and you got
this
you're representing me in a court of law
I don't know what's happening well I am
a lawyer by training so that's how this
works out here so perhaps you know we
can enter a plea and go from there but
hey my friend oh I've known you for for
years and the one thing I when I think
of you I think about your hustle like I
think about you at events or where I was
performing as well Mo coming in and then
flying out I have to leave in an hour if
I'm flying to another gig or I'm doing
two gigs or I'm trying to record a
documentary about this travel I'm doing
in Jordan when we're in Jordan and when
I watched the series Mo if that jumps
out at me like you've captured not just
your hustle but like the hustle of my
immigrant dad who's also Palestinian how
much was that important to you to get
that across the people that the life of
an immigrant is constant Hustle
yeah I think it was um a natural theme
to like step into it wasn't even like
should we do it or should we not do it
it was just uh like you said it was a
part of my life and uh for so many years
I didn't even have a passport so the
countries that I would tour and do
stand-up in uh sometimes I wasn't even
supposed to be in but I'd find loopholes
to get there I would you know figure it
out if I was touring Europe I would have
to fly into Germany because of Schengen
law was in place I could go to other
countries domestically travel to them
while you know finding this loophole so
it was just like my entire life hasn't
been that way and I feel like you know
it's like the mentality immigrant has
like you have to outwork everybody uh
that's what I was told you got to be the
funniest you got to work harder than
everyone you got to be you know you just
have to be that guy and uh yeah it's
just a natural thing to step into
um yeah I don't know what else to say
other than that I mean when you see
people to go into that right when you
when you said like you were told you
have to work harder than anyone was that
like a voice inside of you or was that
someone and what I mean by that is my
dad was an immigrant well tell me you
have to work work work hard my mom who
Sicilian would tell me you have to go
after what you want and take it right so
that was called shoplifting but still
yeah but by my but the two of them
merged together but literally my dad
it's not just immigrant work ethic he
would tell me I've come to this country
I'm working hard I'm working hard for
you and your family you have to work
hard as well and people actually say it
did you hear it or was it more like
implicit in the way watching your your
family work really hard it's both I
think a little bit of both uh but I also
noticed the landscape of entertainment
and stand up and I realized like you
can't just wait you know you just can't
wait if you're waiting on someone to
give something to you and then it really
parlays into life as well it's not just
entertainment and any kind of job that
you're pursuing or anything that's
this big of a dream for sure you can't
just sit there and be like why aren't
they doing this why aren't they giving
it to me like you can't do it you can't
you don't have time to whine like you
have to like push push push and outwork
everybody and I've you know and that's
something that was like I pursued really
aggressively and I would tour I
like like a madman I would tour like a
man but like you said and I would I've
worked 50 countries at this point doing
stand-up comedy and what I love and I
did 25 of those countries without a
passport and so many people told me I
can't go you can't make it why would you
go there why would you put yourself
through it and I you know
it was just something that had to be
done and I noticed that very quickly
that to also get noticed and to to to
make progress and that's how I made
these like really you know I work with
my heroes now because of that hard work
you know because that I've been able to
step into it that way and when you
mentioned putting yourself in difficult
positions you Yuri's MO is really
really sums up so much of what you're
about
each episode's like what what's going to
happen now and people have seen some of
the episodes and how like how are you
gonna get out of it is the question is
watching but to take a big step back
though and again this is personal but
being a Palestinian Heritage and seeing
a Palestinian family that you've
presented is unlike anything I've ever
seen in my life and it's something I've
wanted to see and it's something people
in our community it's so resonated
deeply with them how important when when
you were making this was it to tell your
story but also to tell the
palestinian-american story
yeah it was really really important to
uh humanize a middle eastern
specifically Palestinian family while
also showcasing a Christian Palestinian
character as well was very very
important because I think they're just
forgotten in all this uh which is really
not
you know something that really breaks my
heart because they do exist and people
forget about this so it was very
important to do so uh but also like the
universality of the family as well is
crucial you I always think of like FUBU
was like for us by us but this was like
for us for everyone it's not it was
intended to be like a you know the
vehicle as a Palestinian family but
they've delivered a message of like
struggle of wanting to belong wanting to
be seen uh feel represented uh you know
the Fish Out of Water Element of it all
and and finally like you know it it was
always like shocking for people to
realize you've been in the country so
long but you still don't have
citizenship because you're so American
and you pay taxes so just to deliver
that through the family was really
really special and into you know bring
in some stuff that is like incredibly
nice to us whether it's like olive oil
or hummus but now becoming really global
and I always see I've always seen that
like this stuff is coming it's like
whatever whatever countries being
invaded and look at that we export their
food right away look that's what happens
and the food becomes a big part of the
culture and so that's like
um it's really it's really important to
take you know uh uh ownership of those
things and to show the world like okay
if you're gonna consume it at least
consume it like it's supposed to be and
so it was it was really important really
really important it's interesting to do
right because you have the hummus seen
when you're in the store and the people
have flavored hummus I live in New York
people think at this point that hummus
is like American because it's everywhere
like and you're trying to reclaim it by
going but this is Ours by the way okay I
I'm glad you're enjoying this but we are
the ones that gave it to you you know
all you touch on your immigration status
in the show you talk about going for
years being seeking Asylum seeking want
legal immigration status which can allow
you to work legally and to live your
life and to dream and it took your
family in the show a long time share a
little bit about how it's actually
inspired by your own family and your own
trials and tribulations here in America
where you guys family came here from
Kuwait just to get some legal
citizenship standards status
yeah so it took us a long time it took
me 20 years almost to get my citizenship
into my real life
um and the and people think like when
you come here as a asylee or a refugee
it happens really quickly when it
doesn't unless you get married you know
unless you get married and most of them
are not real right and you fake out the
system or whatnot it's just it's just
that's the only way to get through it
it's like the system is set up for you
to do illegal shit that's the way it is
it's like they want you to be legal and
you want me to be so perfect but the way
it's set up it pushes you to your moral
limits you know and and it's really
really hard it took my mother almost 21
years it took me 20 took my brother 20.
uh and say everything even goes
perfectly in your acai lead process okay
you get your Asylum granted all right
great you get a court case like rapidly
and some miracle you get it granted you
have to wait five years before or you
get your green card once you get your
green card you gotta wait another four
years and nine months before you can
apply for your citizenship So you you're
talking about 10 years if everything
just goes perfectly
which it doesn't because the immigration
system is a mess and it puts you in
situations that are very difficult it's
really unfair
um while you're you know being
upstanding citizens and taking care of
the things you need to while it's really
sad for people who are a lot older you
know at least I was young and was even
then it was like I'm sure you can't go
back and visit your family you can't go
back to any locations that you're seeing
this island from because you just can't
while you're waiting for your
citizenship it's just not a good look
and so imagine all the years apart from
your family at least now you have face
time you're able to like communicate
with them but imagine I don't even like
see their face for my mom wasn't able to
go back to the place where she was born
37 years
it's as a lawyer it's confusing I mean I
don't practice law anymore thankfully
but even as a lawyer you read about this
you're like how unjust and unfair
there's something else that's unjust and
unfair that you portray I think people
have heard about in the news but I've
never seen it in a scripted show and
that is how undocumented immigrants or
people of this kind of Uncertain status
are preyed upon by American citizens
because you can't go to the police and
they know that and that comes up why was
that important because share a little
bit about how that was partic depicting
the show does it match up with your own
experience
yeah no it does because you were just
excited how things could look and
anything that goes on your record
could harm your status forever like you
know it could be it could be one little
word on a police report that could be
taken in some way and then you're ruined
like literally your whole life is ruined
so it's very very important to stay out
of trouble you can't get if you get a
traffic ticket it could go against you
anything any little mishap could could
ruin any your chances of getting
citizenship and with us being stateless
being you know uh not having a country
you know to could could you could get
deported on your own recognizance which
means like you're effectively deported
for the rest of your life until you
you'd have to be like essentially then
forced to married it that's the only way
you can get out of it
it's it's a remarkable thing and by the
way people know it it's funny too with
the show I mean we're talking about yeah
it's hilarious this is what happens
every time my interview's like so
serious because of the subject matter
well people watch this first few
episodes before they've watched this at
least you should have and if you haven't
go back and watch them and come back but
that you'll see it's a comedy but it you
rate also the other part you intersect
so well with other immigrant communities
it's not like you know my dad was an
immigrant here and immigrants I know
they tend to intersect with other
immigrant communities because you're
sharing a similar Journey
um in yours in your case it has to do a
lot with the Spanish community and you
hear the Latino community and your
girlfriend and it's Latina and you hear
Spanish when you're Arabic we hear
English which is so much the soundtrack
of The Immigrant Community you hear
different languages how important was
that and was that based on reality that
your girlfriend yeah
Cheryl I know that I know and since it's
no it's definitely based off of like
yeah it's like so Houston itself though
a leads to suburb I grew up in where
most of the show takes place has 90
languages spoken in it you know that's
why like 90 languages it's the most
diverse city in America uh and we wanted
it I really really wanted it to be like
a character within the show itself and
the only way to show that authentically
is to code switch pretty regularly and
you know from language to language and
my best friend in the show Toby wigwe
who's you know Nigerian uh and blowing
up as a rapper right now it's just like
killing it but he you know there's a
huge Nigerian population here in Houston
as well I would say that Hakeem Olajuwon
is directly the reason for it of why you
had so many Nigerians uh move to Houston
but uh like yeah it's just like a it's a
it's a real uh reflection of what it's
like to grow up in Houston
uh how big of a city is yet so you know
one of the nicknames is H-Town it really
does feel like a small town buy with one
of the most diverse populations of
America crazy
and it's also interesting when you talk
about Houston like there's love in your
voice and in the show and here you are
you're an immigrant you know your family
is Palestinians via Kuwait you come here
but I think the love you have that we
see in Houston is so much of the
Immigrant experience you still love your
the country your origin but you you grow
to love America and and how important
was that for people to see even though
it was subtle at no point to do like
here's a tutorial on immigrants yeah
yeah you love your new city but of
course you still love your Palestinian
roots and where you're from
yeah I think like how can you love
yourself if you don't know where you
come from you know like how I really
like
really believe that but you have to
keep those ties and everybody does that
everybody pretends like it's just like
an Arab thing or a but are you like a
non-white thing to do so but
um white people love where they come
from too you know that Saint Patty's Day
you got you got okay you know it's all
kinds of songs and chance that exists uh
historically for them so it's like it's
it's I think it's big it's natural to
want to know where you come from and and
have ties with it and love it and
simultaneously loving where you're from
I am an American I am of a deep
gratitude for Houston the city that
adopted only me but my family and and uh
it's treating me so well uh it loves me
and lifts me I'm a Texan you know I I
support that I'm a southerner I'm proud
of that like I I have a deep sense of
Pride for all these things and I also
feel like there's a lot of parallels
there in the in the folk music we have
as Palestinians we have folk music we
have old timing music that we attach to
these great stories and so do
southerners there's Bluegrass deeply
painful blues music that we I also
resonate with as well so it's just like
there's these great prayer parallels
that that I think get ignored which I
don't think is right I think there's a
deep connection so I I love that I grew
up in the South I loved that I grew up
in Houston and I'm very very proud of
that and also Houston has never had a
narrative sitcom filmed in it ever which
is my way of giving Houston its flowers
and we've created so much revenue here
in Houston because of the show I'm so
excited about that and thrilled to to be
you know uh contributing part of that
like it's huge it's huge you're
amazingly hyphenated when you think
about it you're not just like Arab
American you're Palestinian Arab
American you're Houston American your
your section you're a southern American
you have a lot going on and again it's
it's Unique damn right yeah exactly and
you're proud of it the you know the word
you said in the answer strikes me and
resonates with me and I don't think a
lot of Americans and I say this
truthfully that aren't immigrants or
children of immigrants get it and that
word was gratitude I have so much
gratitude this country gave my father a
chance to come here and gratitude that
they let my Sicilian grandparents come
to this country before that so I'm very
protective of the American dream I'm
very protective of what this nation's
supposed to be and protected in the
sense of fighting its bigotry and hate I
mean do you feel that when you're about
gratitude is that part of it
of course yeah I feel all of that I feel
like it's you know you didn't know you
know you didn't know what you're in for
when you first moved to America I was
nine years old uh uprooted uh pretty
quickly from the life that was really
spectacular and normal and you know
family all around us to just being in
Houston and then a day later Halloween
happens and nobody explains it to you
and you're like where the fuck did I
move to you know what I mean like he's
like what happened but then very quickly
you realized like how special and unique
this place is and the opportunity that
it can't get you I mean look at all the
things that had to happen for me to
achieve what I've achieved like the war
like multiple fleeing of wars and
situations that happened before I was
even born that I'm bored and then the
Gulf War happens nine years later you
move to Houston Texas and a little kid
sees stand-up comedy for the first time
at 10 years old realizes that's what he
wants to do four years later he's doing
it his father dies goes on this journey
though so many no's in front of me no no
no no no no it's all I hear you can't do
it impossible the uh the way but the
city supports me the people are there I
love it I tour I get a mentor one of the
best mentors to to do stand up truly in
Houston Danny Martinez puts him on his
wings teaches me everything
releases me to the world I start touring
and the rest is history like that is
the American dream that is like truly
what it is believe in yourself
understanding that there is no limits
and you have to outwork anybody because
it's all about the hustle whether you're
an immigrant or not you're gonna have to
also very very hard to truly get to your
goal nobody's gonna give it to you you
have to earn it and there you go and
it's you know I have a lot of gratitude
as well for how long the journey has
been I was always raised on like Fast
rise fast fall so I'm very grateful to
have like all this time and experience
because this show you know came out
exactly what it was supposed to I
believe it is timely and I believe that
it's timeless it lives on and you don't
have to be an Arab to relate to it it
could be anybody it could be anybody
like literally anyone who's struggled to
fit in somebody who hustles every day
living to paycheck to paycheck that
really is trying to make it then just
achieve their dream while trying to
maintain their spirituality and their
family wellness
and maybe not working it's not working
no matter how hard they do it and it's
not you mentioned that
you have to hustle regardless if you're
you're born here or an immigrant and I
think that's different I think for
children of immigrants or immigrants you
expect it to be a hospital and I think
there are certain Americans and we can
call them we know who they are that they
they think it should be handed to them
and no it's not if you come in that
mindset you'll be disappointed you
relies to be a challenge you mentioned
before we wrap up here you mentioned
your father passed away in real life and
that shows up in this show here do you
think back on your father now and how he
would see this and see this TV show
every day
that's it I can't talk about it okay I
understand my friend it rips me apart it
rips you apart I think about it all the
time it's great but it's a beautiful
tribute to him in the show and if
someone lost my father years ago I
understand we're gonna have like two
emotional comedians here
it's not pretty and last thing that
people only watch the first two episodes
what would you tell them
why did you go watch the rest of it on
that it's only like five more episodes I
think it's a great series but what would
you say to them oh so so the shows yeah
so the show's intentionally shot in two
parts like it's uh it's like a two-part
movie so the first four episodes have a
certain particular purpose in the last
four episodes have another purpose so
you're definitely missing out if you
just watch the first part of the movie
and don't finish taking a nap it's
ridiculous everything comes together the
five five six seven eight will fly by
like you'll be upset how fast it flies
by it just like everything has a
particular purpose every sound every
piece of music everything has a purpose
when it's moving forward and you you'll
want to you'll need to watch it again to
catch everything truly because there's
so many little little hidden gems
throughout the series and episode seven
truly brings it all back and you really
start understanding everything with the
flashback in episode five and then what
happens in episode seven six and spring
I I I love the closing the the five
through eight is crazy
big Cliffhanger and you know it it goes
in directions people are not going to
expect but it's true to you the whole
time at its moment is again mope you can
watch it on Netflix right now in fact
when you stop watching this go watch the
rest of mo mo congratulations on the
critical Acclaim it's a heartwarming
beautiful and funny series and I I can't
recommend enough for people it was great
chatting with you here today thanks
brother
take care thank you very much love man
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]